yeah and he's likeed the way they've started
they've come out physical they've come out fast
he said the biggest thing to them is execution
keep it simple and just execute he trusts their
skill fires Kudos Z time shot save by Campbell
so early on he stops Joel fary as the Oilers
try to regroup not much happening so far just one
shot on goal each York cam York cam York into the
glove of Campbell Nifty move by number with the
new number cam cam York did not make the team out
of Camp last year he had a chip on his shoulder
he was motivated and you know what he said before
their last game against Dylan Holloway it's easy
win for the veteran lton against the young Hollow
whoa behind his own net and Har has to cover
up looking for Adam Ernie the former Red Ring
who the Oilers signed in the off season here
come the Oilers again Yan Mark makes a move
shot nice save by har beautiful move by ymark
to go around sanheim if back come the Flyers
the other way they AR and Brink squirts out and
comes right to Edmonton and kulak will skate it
out of the zone and Chip it up towards Fogle nice
play by sanheim though to get it right to far and
back on the Flyers watch out PR me to [Applause]
[Music] BR what a play by Bobby Brink game for
the Oilers coming down and that allowed them to
come right back in it's fogal that sort of gives
up on the puck there and now they're coming in
with with some uh some speed and some creativity
and by the way if you're the Edmonton Oilers in
this situation you think you're getting off for
a change fers were good in the faceoff dot they
had more block shots than Evon they just wanted
it a bit more let's see if Evon wakes up and
has a better second period hey they don't hand
out that Stanley Cup thing for eight more months
on ABC so I get it you're not going to come out
and play with cup cont uh intensity every night
if you're Edmonton but they got to pick it up a
little bit here well they do and that's the part
of the thing when you listen to these guys Conor
McDavid Leon Dr will talk about the teams that
they've lost to the last two years they've lost
the team that went on to win the cup Colorado
and Vegas golden night they said there was an
intensity to their game but they're trying to
replicate they got room now McDavid with dry
sidling Kane in front shot Save By Heart talks
a lot about how Conor McDavid can draw people
to him and he makes these big passes or they use
the width of the ice look how Tri setle throws it
across through body he's going to trickle around
and McDavid and Kane both go down and mcdavid's
going to flex that left knee and make a change
Here Comes tippet now tippet got ainson in front
goes to him SC Cam Atkinson off the beautiful
backhand feed from Owen tippet and the Fly guys
are up two nothing place for turnovers that the
Flyers has taken advantage of for both of their
goals good work here to get the puck and then
just put it to the net he's on his backand there
he could have putting on his forehead try to get
a shot but Tiff it instead recognizes that ainon
and the Flyers lead two nothing if the owners
thought it was going to be easy think again
but they got a two-on one Fogle shot Sav by heart
as two players go smashy into the boarding second
here's this Rush coming out of the Zone quick a
rush and you know what can't have that mid-season
uniform change you know well better been a name
change right in terms of pronunciation McDavid
Off the Bench looking for the W around back to
home kick save and a beauty from Carter Harts
who gets up slowly and delorier but nurse now
takes it he'll skate it out pass it up here comes
Ryan to the net Derek Ryan Puck is loosed and
it squirts to the corner penalty coming up and
that vaunted power play is going to get their
second chance best power play on to the ice as
Derek Ryan there makes a nice move Newen Hopkins
Bard watching McDavid two Open men in front Hyman
McDavid knocks it down on of midair he's looking
for a shooting Lane in front Hyman can't get it by
hards power play unit and he's just not able
this looks like it was going to be a gim watch
him right in front of Carter her and then he
slides over gives himself space and just that
little shove from sanheim gets him balance
he's unable to he's an energy guy for this
Edmonton team tridal see if woodc starts to
throw some of these lines in a in a blender
bit and right now he is himman with McDavid and
dryo score on Q blender activated and it results
in a goal a Zach Heyman goal Emy ORS have cut
the lead two to one on Hyman's second of the
year they've gone to that nuclear time where
they put him together at the end of the game
so he is used to it Vander Kane got a little
banged up but heyman's great in front of the
neck what he does really well what he's done on
the second line in this new lineup and then now
here is he works he just goes into it and he's got
the point he wasn't able to elevate the puck when
he gets an opportunity on the power play but he
makes no mistake here and wood that's one of the
skills is offense rebound what a save by Camp
R around no it's kicked out Bobby Brink inches
away from his first NHL goal couldn't quite get
the toe around the post to try to find it he just
little bit premature one timer nice sa by Hart
really had to fight that one off was a bit of a
block shot knuckle Puck through a lot of traffic
as well Flyers doing a good job so far taking
away those shooting lanes and stealing the puck
and here they come shorthanded shot [Applause]
score sha Walker's first of the year [Applause]
shorthanded the defenseman has given the Flyers
their two goal lead back setting up they were
moving and looked like they had it going Conor
McDavid has the puck and what an incredible
pickoff by couturier and you know what I expected
him to ice the puck instead a little backhand
sauce they're off of the races two on two at
the last second coutu tried to join the rush he
didn't need it though Shan Walker with a rifle
lets the player get behind him there's not much
he can do it's a beautiful feed by K right up the
middle and it's been a good night for the Flyers
kkny to lton backand penalty coming up on kulak
and the Flyers will end the period and begin the
next on the power play coup this last summer in
Nashville getting the Russian Mee cop was off to
a great start cutter goer plays the Boston College
would likely join them in March after Boston
College's season is over doesn't have tons of
Leverage as an RFA but it'll be interesting to see
how Keith Jones and Daniel Brier deal with this
[Applause] [Music] goenda spicy dangle from Cam
Atkinson his second goal of the game Cam Atkinson
is having a game came alive especially in this
second period but good job by the Flyers to break
the puck out they've got great support coming
up the board getting it out and then there's
a great heads up play recognizing you got tippet
who recognizes it's right there tippet got the P
good move by Aon short hand now dry Sidle is out
there but here come the Flyers three on two with
the man Advantage sa is over aington the extra
pass the shot save by Campbell Here Comes ping
halfway sends it towards delorier can't connect
near George hesitation number eight another guy
you can see that confidence just growing save
by Campbell that's on a three-game point streak
looking to keep it alive as when they started
with two go two goals in the first game of the
season two years left here comes in alone back
and save by heart as he denies Fogle to keep it
4 to one and you we heard John tordella tell
you he's the backbone of this team he's been
unbelievable Owen Tipp it for his first of the
year but it's snared by Campbell as they take
care of business against the Edmonton Oilers at
home home opener was Tuesday second one also a
win